you are a far different person now  from who you were when we met back to  school ring the bell brand new shoes  why do you continue to come here because  I enjoy our time together  my friends just came out thank you let's  give you a nickname  pirate king Wicked  MR Hurricane has anyone ever tried to  take advantage of you  how'd you deal with that  harshly  you know  hey buddy  I've got some really bad news  back if it seems appropriate Mr Harrigan  I wish that you were here  I got him beat up pretty bad at night  I want him to get what he deserves  foreign  [Music]  that made me an accessory  it's a tragic accident that's all  [Music]  foreign  a person shouldn't call out unless they  want an answer  [Music]